bonjour et bienvenue pour ce stop
science consacrée aujourd'hui aux
extraterrestres et autres petits hommes
verts commençons d'abord par quelques
points de définition un extraterrestre
qu'est ce que c'est excuse moi mais il
me semble que tout le monde sait ce
qu'est un extraterrestre les gens sont
pas idiots non plus jeter de cet avis
effectivement et puis j'ai vu ça la vie
extraterrestre
insurgés des profondeurs de l'océan ah
ouais d'accord on va pour la définition
alors donc un extraterrestre comme son
nom l'indiqué c'est un être vivant qui
vient d'une autre planète que la terre
étant donné les milliards de galaxies
qui existent les milliards des toiles
qu'elles contiennent que chacune possède
certainement un système planétaire alors
on peut être à peu près sûr que des
extraterrestres existent mais la grande
question est à quoi ressemble-t-il
sachant leur foisonnante diversité des
formes vivantes sur terre
on pourrait croire que les designers et
les artistes qui tentent d'imaginer ce à
quoi ressemble la vie extraterrestre sur
la preuve d'une imagination pour le
moins débordante il n'en est rien au
contraire on nous accable de banalités
et d'un médiocre entrepôt centrisme dont
superman d'ailleurs est le meilleur
exemple
ne cherchez pas c'est super a attribué
sa terrestre à part prononcé pour les
costumes flashy d'un avocat
et pour ce qui est des autres et bien
voici quelques petites recettes basiques
pour faire des extraterrestres
simplement chez vous à la maison vous
prenez un homme vous les mettez une que
singer vous obtenez sangoku vous le
super guerrier de l'espace
prenez un homme à peu ratatiner
verticalement mettez lui une ampoule au
wild web et vous obtenez dit
prenez un homme mais non j'ai vu avec un
chat tome belle niche à peynier le tout
en bleu et vous obtenez un avis vous
prenez un homme vous le mélanger avec
une lime il vous ajoutez un magnifique
symbole disons phallique 1 voilà et vous
obtenez un alien rsa c'est juste comme
vous vous demanderiez où se trouve le
symbole phallique et comme les
extraterrestres sont pas directement
inspirée de silhouettes humaines il
s'agit en fait de bestioles qui vivent
sur terre dès fois appel micheline voici
dans starship troopers des pièces
d'artillerie sur pattes qui sont en fait
des scarabées bombardier ici c'est un
koala noir lilo et stitch s'est planté
en spirale dans avatar est en fait la
troupe va vers spiro graf et ça c'est le
cas phare de men in black
des hommes des animaux il ne reste plus
qu à mélanger les deux un homme araignée
dans star wars voici satan précis
l'homme mouche le maroc qu'il attendait
est ce que c'est un homme est ce qu'un
modèle devient noir la ceca gilman et
pour finir c'est intelligent c'est un
peu tout de même c'est pas comme si dans
le monde réel il n'avait jamais existé
d'êtres vivants aux formes extravagantes
ici jamais les espèces actuelles ne vous
inspire pas prenez-en des fossiles c'est
pas les fossiles bizarre qui manquent
bon on peut admettre qu'il y ait
quelques contraintes d'ordre technique
comme de faire rentrer quelqu'un qui a
deux bras qui a deux jambes dans un
costume et puis il faut que le public
soit pas trop largué par défendre trop
extravagant
bah oui comment pourrait-on s'attacher à
un personnage dont on sait maintenant
qu'il est de qq de guider la tête
s'approche ou s'éloigne
si c'est une film manque de biodiversité
cela se doit beaucoup au fait que les
extraterrestres sont souvent créées sans
souci d'une éventuelle histoire
évolutive
prenons l'exemple de pitch black dans
pitch black les héros sont poursuivis
lors d'une éclipse par des
extraterrestres ressemblant alléchant
sourire et hante mes cils une
extraterrestre de pitch black avait une
histoire évolutive
alors la sélection naturelle n'y aurait
pas laissé filtrer des aberrations aussi
énorme qu'une espèce nocturne dimension
une planète où ne fait nuit qu'une fois
tous les bonnes deux ans vous direz que
la lumière le pendule il n'ya pas nuire
et kamel ouali qui se déplace dans des
cavernes en volant eh ben c'est bien
connu que le meilleur moyen de se
déplacer dans une keller de cette volée
bien sûr mais alors soyons un peu
sérieux
si les chauves-souris vol c'est parce
qu'elles peuvent sortir voler tous les
soirs c'est extra terrestres là ne sorte
qu'une seule fois tous les 22 ans
s'il avait été un tant soit peu réaliste
il aurait dû ressembler à des tops par
des chauves souris
évidemment ces incohérences n'ont qu'un
but mettre en valeur le héros un
meurtrier qui va dans le noir et qui
doit se racheter une conscience en
guidant les survivants d'un crash sur
cette planète
bref inventaire une biodiversité tout
fait c'est lui faire répondre à un
cahier des charges souvent plus
esthétique et pratique que logique
alors que la sélection naturelle elle
n'a pas de cahier des charges ni de but
smic un filtre qui ne laissera pas c'est
que ce qui est capable de survivre et de
se reproduire efficacement dans un
environnement donné
c'est pourquoi l'évolution est logique
pas la création et oui l'évolution est
génératrice de biodiversité pas la
création l'évolution façonnent les
vivants et pas quelle image de l'homme
mais très peu de films de sf font
l'effort d'inventer une histoire
évolutive à leurs protagonistes
le film évolution fait partie de ceux là
on y voit apparaître et se développer
des formes de vie original parfois ne
ressemblant à rien du tout bel effort
mais même ce film finit par tomber dans
mr anthropocentrique on retrouve le même
travers dans le film avatar
regardez toutes les créatures sur
pandora elles ont deux paires d'yeux
deux paires de bras et des branchies
tout sauf les na'vi bien sûr mais
pourquoi pourquoi à paris moi pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi
mais pour que jake sully fils s'est
fermé thierry et ben ouais c'est sûr que
nike thierry elle serait quand même
vachement moins sexy comme ça
heureusement les créateurs d'avatar ont
pensé à inclure projets mûrissent
un petit l image dont on comprend que
les bras à 2000 fusionner l'unique père
dieu et la présence simultanée d'un
épais de branchies furent office
d'intermédiaire entre le pain doria
lambda et denali ah oui une sorte de
chez normand a lieu un d'intermédiaires
structurale pardon mais encore une fois
pourquoi on allait mourir
pourquoi l'énergie descendre équipe de
quelque chose qui ressemble à un singe
alors qu'il ressemble davantage à mon
chat ces deux films tombe en fait dans
le travers classique une idée reçue
selon laquelle une forme de vie
intelligente ne peut pas exister sans
être forcément humanoïdes comme si
l'évolution se faisait par stade et que
le stade ultime devait impérativement
ressembler à un être humain mais en y
réfléchissant un outil pas pour quelle
raison des extraterrestres évoluera-t-il
vers une forme même vaguement humanoïdes
pourquoi anthropomorphes serait il
synonyme d'intelligence alors que tant
de combinaisons sont possibles
est-ce donc si compliqué d'imaginer
autre chose tenez prenez l'exemple du
roman nemesis d'isaac asimov
dans cette histoire il existe une
planète peuplée de bactéries
intelligente car elles sont reliées
entre elles comme les neurones d'un
cerveau unique à l'échelle planétaire
comme quoi il n'ya pas besoin d'aller
chercher très loin pour se dire qu'une
intelligence est possible autrement que
sous une forme humaine mais évidemment
tout le monde n'est pas isaac asimov ce
conflit souvent les créateurs
d'extraterrestres c'est le hasard
le hasard de la mutation de l'adn les
mutations du code génétique sont
capables de donner de tout ou presque de
tout mais attention car le filtre de la
sélection naturelle ne laisse pas passer
n'importe quoi mais en tenant compte de
cette part de lazard on comprend que
l'histoire de l'évolution sur terre ne
peut pas se répéter
elle devient imprévisible on reprend à
l'heure à quel point la probabilité
qu'une vie extraterrestre et développer
de l'adn comme source d'information
génétique etc en plus leur code
génétique sont suffisamment semblables
pour qu'ils puissent hybride et est
infinitésimal pour vous leur présentez
dites vous qu avec plus de 95% de gènes
en commun
on ne peut déjà pas s'hybrider avec les
chimpanzés alors avec les
extraterrestres nous on ne va pas non
plus accablé les film d'extraterrestres
pour l'heure anthropocentrisme puisque
c'est pareil par exemple dans les films
de robots mais oui pourquoi un
ordinateur qui veut exterminer les
humains créer des robots qui leur
ressemblent avec une bouche qui ne leur
sert à rien et des dents des dents mais
pourquoi des dents pour manger des
écrous mais pourquoi le disque dur de
cette carcasse métallique gigantesque et
a découvert dans sa tête il pouvait pas
être sous la plaque de blindés allemands
la réponse est simple anthropocentrisme
pour conclure si vous voulez vraiment
imaginer à quoi une vie extraterrestre
peut ressembler commencer par oublier
tout ce que vous connaissez
évitez l'anthropocentrisme et penser
évolution merci à tous
ce qu'a dit j'ai bien regardé l'épisode
d'aujourd'hui
j'ai découvert un truc complètement
insensé révolutionnaire c'est vraiment
fait moi voir tu vois ça c'est le projet
mûrisse d'avatar ça c'est l'espèce de
sage bleus bizarre dans l'évolution et
ça ce sont les na'vi dans avatar
tu vois ce que dit tout est lié
c'est l'évolution mais non il va où là
et au bad revient bien j'ai pas fini